[音楽]
me
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
最近 acg 柄か dc 実践が頭をなぞってます上田純也と申します
今回この私はですね4 tg ぜ世界を変えるというテーマでお話しさせていただき
ます
ちょうど5年前私は大学を大学入学を機にイ
9滋賀県に行きました
そして大学入学を機に居讐約卒業
今年の春大学を卒業し今フリーで働いています
最近働き方がご自由になったおかげで同じの働くたについて
あまりこう深く聞かれることはないのですが唯一
惹かれることはこの
いつからそんなに君愛知高くなったのだったりとか
いつからそんなに幸をアクティブに行動するようになったのか
いつからそんな高哲学的な価値観を持ちになったのということはよく聞かれますしかし
私自身
具体的にですね聞かれても g セコイきてたらいろんなことを学ぶのでなかなかこお
答え
低いというのがありますしかし集5
私自身具体的に言える日があるんですね
それは
2016年4月中4日
それは忘れもしない僕にとっての大切な日です
私の補強の熊本県がこのような自信にまいりました
まで覚えてるんですよね
あの大学 no ですね図書館でレポートをしに行っている時にお母さんと弟から急に
電話かかってきて
今どこにいるの大丈夫今何してるの
テレビたみたいなかなり子焦った声
結構宮木ついててで実はその電話がピソで家に帰ってテレビをつけると
この写真が出てたんですよねは自分の子知ってる写真映像が警備する位牌投稿
まああの頃になんていうかね言葉にできないというか難しい感じになっています
またさらに追い打ちをかけなんですね自分のお家がもなくなるとほとんどかた後方は
なくならないとさらにこれはこの神話ですね自分の祖母の家ということで行った時には
もうあの
なんてですかね実際高原針た時はこうなんとも言い難く手取りは写真撮るかぐらいしか
できないんですよね
っていう風な某状態中で今約3年くらいは去ってきて少しずつ
私自身はこのような自分の経験したことを言語ができるようになって来ましたあそこで
学んだのは2つです
まず1つがですね
学びの無力さについてです
私自身例えば最近公平性は災害次第だと言われていますが実際に東日本大震災などを
リアルにをテレビで見ていた自分がいたんですよね
なんとなくこうわかったつもりで自分自身ありました
しかもまあ次私たちが来るなんて思ってもないですから
まあたぶんいけるでしょみたいな感じもそうですしまた小学校週学校高校大学と皆さん
経験してといいますが
防災訓練でありますね
全然私自身結果としてですねまああの役に立たなかった
これいろいろあると思いますが私にとっては逆になれなかったというか私何もでき
なかったというのがいい
またもう一点それは自分の人生というものが連続している
をということについて違和感を持ち始めたことです
宇崎どういうことか少し分かりづらいかもしれませんが自分自身の通っていた小学校の
例えば通学路がテレビでも本当にしっちゃかめっちゃかになってると
をまた自分のいた家がなくなると一瞬で効果子が亡くなった時に私たちは自分のこれ
からの10年後20年後てものが
どうなるかというのを本当に想像できなくなるということで私は自分の人生が本当に5
連続
これから未来永劫続いていくのかということに違和感を持っています
そんな中ですね大学生活をしているととある友人でありました
その友人が僕に教えてくれたことはこの stg ず
と言われるものです
私何言ってるかも全然わからなかったところもあります
しかも僕自身はなく中にの友人友人とお話してて今でこそこんな所で自分の活動のキー
ワードになって勝つ
今からてテーマにも選ばすまたこの言葉ですが当時は何も覚えてませんでした
最近ちょっとこう普段の豪華この子なんですかね
ちょっとした会話ってかそういうのが
大切だなっていうのをこの年前に一つ先感じるようになってきました
で少し説明すると sdg ずといわれるものは
サステイナブルディベロップメントゴールズ持続可能な開発目標と言われるものです
これは国連が2015年に採択した
2030年までの世界を変えるための曲世界共通の目標になっています
最近ではオリンピックをはじめ大阪関西万博でよく当ててくるということで皆さんもし
かしたらご存知かと思いますがこのような素敵な分かりやすい相棒になってます
これから想定されるべき未来の社会課題というものを17この課題として掲げてまして
これらは私たちは発生していく解決していく必要があると言われています
しかしは車常にご問題してもとますそれは何かというと
2030年にまた同じような災害が起こったときに自分自身はまた
学びの学びがわかりなさだったり人生は本当にコーヒー連続だろうかということを
私自身だけでなく例えばこの会場に皆さん
にも同じことを経験してしまうんじゃないかそういうことを常に私は意識して今私たち
が作るべき未来
サステイナブルな社会をどうやったら作れるかというこのを切り
考えています
しかし相手は地球です地球規模の社会方に対して私たちば向き合っていかなければなり
ません
もちろんこの近くにいる人間同士の戦いもちろんありますそれだけじゃ足りないです
地球規模ということで私たちはなかなかこうわかりにくい難しいということで具体的
以降何をすればいいかわからないというような形で行動に打ちにくいと言われています
私はまぁこ stg ということをまあ実践してくる中で最近ちょっとわかってきた
ことがありますそのキーワードはまなぴと言われるものです
私たち得日本人は与えられた学びの中で息継ぎています
かなり行き過ぎていますもちろん
かつ恵まれた環境を教育環境のもとに生まれているということで皆さん平等に
を学びを得ることができています
しかし思い出しください学校に行けば学校の先生が何かしらこう答えを持ってるんじゃ
ないかと思ってあの問題を答えを出すと
とか先生に頭がいいような答えをこうを出してきて
っていうことを小学校中学校もちろんやってきますし
奥 c 最近出たらこう大学ではもしかしたらそういう関係になるんじゃないかという
ことを思ってい
ああああああ
また私たちご受験産業ドラマが発達する中で stg ずに対する
参考書のようなものが同店はあります
そしてそれを見ることによって私たちはしっかりと理解しなければ行動しちゃダメだと
いう風な
まあ
難しいを事前ばに陥ります
またそういうことが発生すると例えば具体的な例でいいますけど高校で実際に出された
問題あります
例えばこれは stg 角17ボールの下にある169のターゲットと言われている
ものですが
9中野1-3にあるものの中で県多久市の中で適切なものは何かということを
高校の試験だされることがあります
それは
私たちはみな同じ答え
同じ行動する必要があるのかということです
私たちは hg 対して多様な人が多様な方法で
たような思いを持って実際に握手をしていくことが求められています
そこで私たちは自ら自分たちに作っていく学びによって社会を変えていくと指示では
ん
それは意外と難しく見えるかもしれませんが実は簡単です
なぜかというとみなさんの所属するコミュニティであったり所属するグループの課題を
プロジェクト化するのです
実際にそのプロジェクトを生活ミッチした形で作り出していって行動すればいいのです
その一つに私はこの stg というものが素晴らしく良いもだと思っています
stg を通して意外なつながりがわたしたちのアイディアや
次につながる行動につながっていくと思っています
それによって私たちは自分と地球という壮大補強とうまく設定を持つことができるん
じゃないかというふうに感じています
そこで具体的な例をいます
サステイナブルいくというものです今日この会場にも来ています
大スターウィークというのは普段学生大学生が生活するキャンパスというものを小さな
こう地球と見立てて自分たちにできることは何かというものを具体的に s チーズを
通して考えていく機会を提供しているイベントです
学生がを主宰して彼らは自分たちでこうアクションを起こしていくっていうことをして
います
もちろんこのような活動を約2年前に起こしずっとしていると社会的に
評価されてきましたまた大学も学生の動きに遅れまいと
st ずをやるっていう専用をしました一般的に良い評価です
ただ僕にとって良い評価というのは学生が自分自身の課題であったり自分地質を想いを
持って実際に自分からプロジェクトを生み出していく
定率ことが要因と考えています
このような形で sdc ずを通して学生たちが
は好きなことを好きな形た様は表現で発信をしています
具体的な例でいうとたとえばこのフェス t ジーズのならバーン
エネルギーの問題で考えると普段音楽の活動して音楽地で様々な学生でも議論してる
学生たちがこの時だけ再生可能エネルギーを使用してライブをするということが出ます
もちろん学生だけではできないので企業の株当たり大学の関係者には変わってもらいな
等多様な学びをたような形で使ってい
また scg の2番に当てはまるような彼らは普段ヘッドボトルのキャップ明日妙な
環境の学生団体です
彼らは自分たちの住んでいる地域にその地域の農家さんが帰ると規格外排気野菜だった
というものを活用してこのや0円カレーというものを提供していました
もちろん参加
葦津れる人にとって素晴らしく良いものであることはあるのですがそれ以上に行って
いる学生自身が自分から自分で作り出す学びを生み出していることがとにかく
素晴らしいのです
そして彼らは何がいいかというと学生みんなで同時にアクションを起こしています
私たちはの社会課題社会を変えることに対して個人でやるとなったらなかなかこう
難しい
ちょっとやめとこうかなというふうになっちゃいますしかし全員が先ほど言った自分の
生活に密着するような形のプロジェクトを起こすことで社会はハイラルではないかと
感じています
sdg 言われるのは誰一人取り残さない社会の実現を掲げています
この壮大な目標に対して私たちが取り組む
私たちがポリー向かい合いやあたっては自分たち自身をに入り私自身もそうでし
この会場に皆さん自身もそうですし自分たちのいるグループだったり
コミュニティの仲間を集めて実際にこう
アクションを起こすことがとにかくし
になったん
2015年までに世界の社会課題と言われ者はハチ子
言われていました
2030年までには17個になると言われています
さあこの2045年次の時代は社会課題はこのように増えるのでしょうかそれとも減る
のでしょうか
今僕はスライドで赤色でこうあの子しチームは方としてへシーツをこう増えるもういい
としてます
一方でパールセーフティな方青色代表される量を
下がる方としています
ただこの世の中には例えば社会方が増えることでビジネスチャンスが増えるという
考える人もいます
一方で社会課題が減ることによって安心で安全な街をを作っていけないかと考えると
思います
このような多様な価値観を持つ人たちの中で私たちは自らが自分たちの考える
コミュニティ18を考えるプロジェクトを進んでい進めていくしかない
最後になりますが私たちは多様な価値観たようなグループの中で皆さんの意思決定をし
ながら社会将来をあるべき姿に持っていくしかないのです
そこで私達は重要なのは一人一人がもちろん
行動することが重要ですけどやっぱりみんなの一歩で社会を変えることが一番重要だと
考えています
以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]